[Musica]
[Applauso]
era estate avevo 10 anni e mia madre mi
disse Ehi tu che sei brava vai di là da
tuo fratello io andai in cucina e lui
era lì al tavolo
millefoglie sparse ovunque che c'è gli
chiesi e lui ventenne
mi aiuti con i compiti i compiti inglese
c'era da tradurre una canzone
e lui non capiva una parola dopo anni
che studiava inglese e io facevo le
elementari così tradusse in fretta
perché mi sembrava assurdo dover aiutare
mio fratello maggiore credevo fosse lui
a dover insegnare a me e proteggermi
farmi ripetizioni
ma lui è autistico e io non lo sapevo
dopo anni ho capito che quella sarebbe
stata la mia vita che io sarei diventata
adulta e lui avrebbe continuato a
chiedermi come fare i compiti o la spesa
Ho letto
e sei sei solo una bambina ma ti rendi
conto di avere una grande responsabilità
capisci che i genitori non sono eterni e
hai sperimentato fin da piccola le prese
in giro le ingiustizie le frasi e gli
sguardi taglienti di chi Osserva i suoi
comportamenti strani chi lo etichetta
chi vi allontana e ti rendi conto che
forse l'unico vero alleato che avrà in
futuro sarai tu
ed è un bel peso sulle spalle per un
sibling termine che in inglese vuol dire
genericamente fratelli e sorelle ma in
italiano nell'ambito della disabilità e
Psicologia si utilizza per indicare
fratelli e sorelle di persone con
disabilità e noi siblings capiamo presto
che il mondo è vario che le cose non
vanno solo in una direzione che gli
standard da seguire per avere un bel
percorso predefinito non tengono conto
della diversità della disabilità e lo
viviamo sulla nostra pelle quando si
invertono i ruoli diventi prima fratello
maggiore e poi genitore di quello che
dovrebbe essere un tuo pari impari a
stare in silenzio non lamentarti Perché
i tuoi problemi non sono importanti
rispetto a quelli di un fratello con
disabilità e cerchi di non pesare sulle
spalle dei genitori così occupati nel
gestire una situazione complicata Quando
sempre a 10 anni andò in campeggio
scrissi una lettera ai miei cari mamma e
papà Io sto bene Non è vero non mi
piaceva il campeggio però fa niente e
spero voi vi stiate rilassando è vero
che siete a casa con altri figli ma uno
in meno è sempre meglio
ero convinta che se non fossi esistita
li avrei alleggeriti
così alle scuole medie mi sono guardata
allo specchio e ho capito una cosa che
mi sarei dovuta arrangiare e in fretta
perché un giorno mi sarei dovuta
prendere cura di lui e quel giorno
sarebbe potuto arrivare anche molto
presto io dovevo correre il doppio
lavorare il doppio guadagnare il doppio
dovevo diventare
adulte responsabile per poter essere la
sua solida spalla e allora finito il
liceo sono andata a studiare a Milano ho
sempre amato il teatro e la scrittura
un'ottima strada per guadagnare il
doppio proprio scelta giusta
a 21 anni lavoravo in TV come autrice e
mi piaceva ma purtroppo ho vissuto una
brutta esperienza di violenza così ho
deciso di mollare tutto pensando di aver
sbagliato di essermi illusa e sono
andata a Parigi lì Ho fatto la cameriera
poi mi sono iscritta all'università Alla
sorbonne filosofia
altra materia ottima per guadagnare il
doppio le scelte giuste proprio e mentre
ero a Parigi sono arrivati i terroristi
e io ho chiesto di fare l'erasmus e sono
andata a studiare in Irlanda per
l'ultimo anno di università sempre alla
ricerca di occasioni nella speranza di
diventare adulte responsabile di trovare
in fretta la mia stabilità Mi sembrava
di fare tantissime cose ma di non
combinare nulla e ormai non ricordavo
nemmeno più da dove venissi così Un
giorno mentre ero in biblioteca e
cercavo risposte nell'analitica
trascendentale mi arriva un'email da mio
fratello Damiano Aveva 35 anni e mi
chiedeva Margherita Mi aiuterai
nonostante tutti mi dicano che per me le
possibilità sono limitate
e io mi resi conto che nella mia
sfrenata ricerca di risposte risultati
Avevo dimenticato il vero motivo della
mia rincorsa correvo Sì ma verso dove
perché lui mi stava ricordando la verità
tutti gli dicevano che non aveva
possibilità
che era troppo stupido troppo ingenuo
troppo autistico troppo tutto o non
abbastanza lo avevano picchiato trattato
male bullizzato lo avevano chiuso in
un'armadietto e preso a calci gli
avevano spaccato il naso con un pugno
lo avevano chiamato water cesso mongolo
ritardato obbligato a ritirarsi da
scuola per poter sopravvivere e ogni suo
tentativo di fare anche solo un piccolo
passo in questo mondo veniva sabotato
e io ero lì davanti a quella richiesta
d'aiuto Lui parlava di possibilità Io
sapevo Anzi io non sapevo cosa volessi
fare ma avevo tante possibilità lui
invece era pieno di sogni ma non aveva
possibilità
sognava di Diventare cantante per farsi
vedere ascoltare lui voleva solo
esistere come chiunque altro ma quando
lo diceva lo prendevano in giro gli
ridevano in faccia
perché la sua voce veniva sminuita è
quella di un autistico
surrealisticamente cosa puoi aspettarti
da uno come lui Così io per la prima
volta mi sono fermata sono tornata in
Italia a casa e l'ho ascoltato l'ho
visto per quello che è una persona
Sì con delle difficoltà ma anche sogni
speranze capacità ero stata così
abituata affrettata nel sulle mie
responsabilità che non avevo mai
dedicato davvero il mio tempo a fare
L'unica cosa forse veramente importante
ascoltarlo
così a Rimini Siamo andati nella sua
cameretta in mezzo a pile con migliaia
di cd poster ventilatori e un universo
ancora inesplorato ci siamo appollaiati
sul letto io l'ho guardato e gli ho
chiesto Damiano Ma
realisticamente che cosa vuoi fare
il cantante
Sì ma come si fa cioè provandoci
E allora ci abbiamo provato siamo usciti
dalla cameretta siamo andati in cucina
Abbiamo preso penne pennarelli carta e
la nostra fantasia e ci siamo messi al
tavolo lo stesso tavolo in cui 15 anni
prima lo avevo trovato in mezzo ai mille
fogli sparsi ovunque gli ha aiutato a
tradurre la canzone in inglese e questa
volta ci abbiamo appoggiato sopra un
foglio uno bianco intonso un foglio da
cui ricominciare questa volta anche
Anche oggi abbiamo scritto una canzone
però la nostra quella di una vita nuova
Sì perché
dovevamo solo scrivere il percorso che
avremmo voluto fare e non quello che gli
altri si aspettavano da noi perché
quando ci siamo realmente
ascoltati e Aiutati reciprocamente
Io ho capito che lui non sarebbe dovuto
solo sopravvivere magari mantenuto da me
Io sofferente lui infelice No lui
avrebbe dovuto vivere che io non sarei
stata la sorella badante ma la sorella a
spalla che la mia vita non sarebbe stata
per lui ma io e lui era Allora di
scrivere un nuovo futuro insieme e
allora su quel foglio non abbiamo
scritto dei deficit della della paura di
non farcela del non riuscire a finire la
scuola di tutte le difficoltà noi
abbiamo scritto abbiamo scritto della
sua passione per la musica delle sue
capacità nel canto della forza di
rialzarsi dopo tutte le botte che ha
preso negli anni
e di quanto io abbia imparato Grazie
all'essere cresciuta accanto a lui sei
sibling vivere la poca tolleranza nei
confronti di una famiglia con disabilità
insegna a batterti per farti ascoltare
vedere le difficoltà di tuo fratello nel
compiere azioni per gli altri banali che
insegna l'importanza di ogni piccolo
traguardo delle cose semplici senza
cercare chissà che cosa vedergli fare il
letto la spesa trovarlo Pettinato ogni
mattina
quest'ultima cosa ancora ci stiamo
lavorando quasi un'utopia ma ce la
faremo e alla fine Quella canzone
l'abbiamo scritta Sì e non solo
L'abbiamo scritto L'abbiamo portata su
tanti palcoscenici siamo stati in
televisione abbiamo scritto un libro che
racconta la nostra storia abbiamo fatto
cose che mai avremmo creduto possibile e
abbiamo capito che
anche Se nasci in un contesto con
condizioni sfavorevoli non vuol dire che
dovrai restarci tutta la vita che le
cose si possono guardare da una
prospettiva diversa che la felicità è
una conquista che richiede tempo e
lavoro e fatica e infiniti momenti di
sconforto ma arriva arriva
e cioè esiste e non bisogna essere
speciali o tutti uguali tutti col conto
in banca a gonfio per essere persone
vive nella vita tutti arroganti tutti
forti perché essendo aggressivi che si
guadagna un posto nel mondo No in realtà
basta così poco Basta credere nei propri
sogni basta la passione l'amore essere
se stessi noi così come siamo senza
concentrarci su quello che ci manca ma
sull'infinità di cose che possiamo fare
con le nostre capacità anche se qualcuno
continua a dirci che non ne abbiamo E
non bisogna arrendersi perché tra gli
scenari della vita c'è anche la felicità
cambia punto di vista e cambierà la tua
vita
[Applauso]